voilà c'est un peu à n'y rien comprendre
ce revirement américain joe biden qui
souffle le chaud et le froid sur cette
possible intervention américaine à l'est
de l'europe armelle charrier bonjour on
va tenter d'y voir plus clair avec vous
on voit bien que dans chaque camp et il
ya une posture la posture des américains
à bord qui menace les européens qui
temporise mais qui montre les muscles
également et puis les heureux que les
ukrainiens qui presque dise circulez ya
rien à voir est-ce que ce conflit c'est
un peu la question que tout le monde se
pose aujourd'hui il ya une chance de le
voir arriver un jour en fait là le
risque le plus important c'est le
dérapage aujourd'hui on est dans une
comme vous le dites il ya deux personnes
qui sont en face les états unis et la
russie qui montre les muscles
les états unis ont certainement
commencer embêter les russes en disant
que les exercices qu'ils étaient en
train de faire n'en étaient pas et qui
se préparait à envahir l'ukraine moscou
a rétorqué que non et l'ukraine dit que
régulièrement il y à autant de monde qui
est massée à sa frontière quand il ya
des exercices russe ensuite moscou
depuis son calendrier c'est à dire elle
fait des manoeuvres en biélorussie et
puis derrière elle fait des manoeuvres
maritimes en ce moment en crimée et puis
en même temps elle fait des manoeuvres
maritimes dans le golfe persique avec
les chinois et avec les iraniens ça veut
dire que en clair elle est en train de
dire tout ça était programmé donc
circulez il n'ya rien à voir mais en
même temps c'est une preuve de puissance
et donc le risque il est que d'abord
quand on est avec deux ego extrêmement
forts qui sont des égouts deux pays mais
qui sont aussi des esgaulx d'individus
on peut aller à l'affrontement et
ensuite à partir du moment donné où vous
déployer autant de monde dans dix
exercices tout tout azimut un moment
donné vous pouvez avoir effectivement
quelque chose qui vous échappe et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que moscou a tendance
à à dire attention on peut avoir des
éléments incontrôlables qui se met en
place mais puisque ce sont des hommes
qui sont déployées au sol au milieu de
tout ça il ya le tandem franco-allemand
qu'on a pu apercevoir hier soir à berlin
il va se réunir aujourd'hui nouveau à
l'elysée sous le format normandie il
peut obtenir quoi au juste on voit que
emmanuel macron continue de privilégier
la carte diplomatique ça peut vraiment
fonctionné alors dans l'absolu non parce
quand on voit entre les russes et les
américains les européens ont été poussés
du doigt et ils ne sont plus dans les
négociations
en même temps comme on est sûr de la
diplomatie chacun quand tu peux faire
preuve en fait de pouvoir s'en sortir va
utiliser la carte qui lui a donné
l'avantagé qu'ont les européens
al'avantage quand les français et les
allemands par rapport aux américains
d'abord c'est qu'ils sont européens
c'est à dire qu'ils sont sur ce
continent là et s'il ya une guerre qui
vient a frappé de craine nous savons est
clairement ce qui va se passer c'est pas
les américains qui vont le subir alors
on entendait dans le sujet quand
effectivement les allemands disent
évidemment il peut y avoir du gaz qui va
être coupée on est en plein hiver
si on coupe le gaz aujourd'hui en
allemagne il va y avoir des foyers qui
vont se retrouver avec plus de chauffage
donc si à un moment donné on est
vraiment sur une crise et que l'on doit
avoir des missiles qui vont passer à
droite et à gauche ce sera effectivement
beaucoup plus compliqué c'est pour cela
finalement qu'à partir du moment donné
où les européens rentrer en jeu il
essaie de rentrer en jeu avec plus de
pragmatisme en disant il faut quand même
essayer un moment donné de faire baisser
cette tension là alors est-ce qu'ils y
arriveront ça c'est à des prend aussi
beaucoup de la demir poutine les
ukrainiens eux aussi ont intérêt à aller
discuter parce que sinon on va se
retrouver dans une situation qui va être
coincé merci beaucoup armelle pour le
décryptage évidemment on suivra l'issue
de cette réunion organisée aujourd'hui à
l'élysée niveau de tension